[Music]
you don't have to tell anyone that
you're studying your selfies but take a
look at them you know you can get really
a lot of tips when you look and I think
between that and quite frankly looking
looking at pop culture but at the end of
the day think about what you wear on a
regular basis and think about how do you
improve that you know if you love a
hoodie there's a way to wear a hoodie
that's more polished it can be trimmer
it could be more luxurious invest in a
cashmere I don't think that that black
or navy jacket that you have sitting in
the closet from eight years ago still
looks perfect always remember you want
to upgrade it you want to update it and
you want to see it evolve kind of look
so find your colors concentrate on
quality not quantity and tailoring
tailoring tailoring I love wearing
sweatpants we all love wearing track
pants think about whether it's a
luxurious take on a sweat pant could be
in a cashmere knit or even think about a
woven sweat pant that's almost like a
trouser but again you want to keep that
neatness so if you are running out to
the deli the minute you put on a great
watch throw in a pair of aviators even
if you're in your old sweats cool
sneakers great watch great glasses if
you run into someone you're not going to
be embarrassed
you
[Music]